Ciao a tutti io sono Loretta Grace e
sono una persona Sì direte come tutti
Certo ma non per questo è qualcosa che
possiamo dare per scontato Eppure è
quello che purtroppo spesso accade
lavorando sul web Questa è la mia
esperienza quotidiana per Chiunque abbia
un personaggio pubblico online c'è una
Challenge che non fa milioni di like
Anzi rischia di portare via tutto ed è
quella con se stessi in cui non bisogna
perdere il contatto con la realtà e
questo accade non perché chi fa i
balletti su Tik Tok è stupido o perché
l'esposizione ai nostri telefoni generi
una condizione neurologica Ma perché
spesso il pubblico specialmente quando
inizia a essere numeroso
celebra attraverso manifestazioni
positive la versione filtrata che ognuno
di noi decide di proporre a chi lo segue
attenzione per filtro non intendo quello
digitale quello che utilizziamo per
apparire più belli di quello che siamo
Intendo la selezione dei momenti che
decidiamo di raccontare la linea
editoriale necessariamente parziale che
racconta un aspetto delle nostre vite e
che si nutre dei nostri contenuti non
sempre alla capacità gli strumenti di
capire qual è il nostro vero racconto
sociale e cioè appena un pezzetto di
qualcosa di più grande Appunto una
persona ma c'è anche l'altra faccia
della medaglia legata alla nostra
Qualcuno dice sovraesposizione che può
farci dimenticare il nostro essere
persone ed è quando riceviamo commenti
di odio e quando questo accade per me
Ormai è chiaro che non si sta parlando
di quello che faccio e come lo faccio
che si può pur certo criticare e non si
sta parlando neanche di quello che dico
dei miei contenuti con i quali si può
essere legittimamente in disaccordo no
per me in quel momento è chiaro
che noi ci Trasformiamo in qualcos'altro
in un bersaglio da colpire tirate giù
quella lì che si è messa su un
piedistallo io non posso sentirmi meno
di qualcun altro ecco quando veniamo
bombardati da conati digitali e rabbia
sintetica la colpa è sempre di chi
distrugge e anche se vi potrà sembrare
paradossale a furia di sentirsi ripetere
determinate cose si rischia di finire
col crederci non è qualcosa che rimane
online e noi andiamo avanti sereni con
le nostre vite no
attraverso le crepe che si allargano sul
display del nostro telefono perdiamo
qualcosa di noi
ed è per questo che voglio cogliere
l'occasione Prima di tutto per ripeterlo
a me stessa Loretta sei una persona e
hai un valore per questo soltanto il
resto viene dopo
ognuno di noi con le proprie azioni con
i propri Talenti e le sue doti
fa qualcosa di straordinario di davvero
importante questo nessuno potrà mai
portarcelo via neanche gli haters
Io sono Loretta Grace
e sono sono qua perché sono qua a questa
domanda me la sono sentita a rivolgere
talmente tante volte che ho deciso di
farmela da sola e parto da qui con la
mia riflessione sul linguaggio che ho
deciso di condividere con voi
per l'appunto perché sono qua lo stavate
chiedendo eh domande Come perché
non ci dovrei essere perché
lo chiedi solo a me nella stanza sono
domande che io mi sono posta da bambina
cercando di capire quale fosse
l'inciampo della comunicazione tra me e
le persone che avevo attorno ma non ci
sono mai riuscita Io sono nata in Italia
non ho mai vissuto in altri paesi Quindi
potete comprendere la difficoltà nel
capire questa situazione un'altra
domanda classica di dove sei Ah questa
qui ha generato infinita incomprensioni
del tipo ma tu tu non sei di qui di dove
sei
no ti sto chiedendo di dove sei
veramente
sono nati in Abruzzo però sono cresciuta
ad Ancona No no no di dove sono i tuoi
genitori
io capivo la domanda non l'intenzione
della domanda
Io sono Loretta Grace sono una cantante
un'attrice e la mia passione per il
beauty mi ha portato ad essere una
digital content Creator Ma come non sei
un influencer magari qualcuno di voi qui
in platea se lo starà pure domandando ma
visto che parliamo di linguaggio e di
uso delle parole proviamo Proviamo a
fare chiarezza Eh no io non sono
un'influencer o almeno non più di quanto
il papa sia un influencer o i politici
siano degli influencer le nostre madri
siano delle influencer ovvero delle
persone che sono capaci di attirare
talmente tanta attenzione verso di sé da
riuscire in parte ad orientare il
comportamento degli altri per questo non
mi ritrova Tanto in questa descrizione
io non faccio proprio questi sono una
creatrice di contenuti digitali che le
persone decidono di seguire questi
decollano In un mondo che è quello del
make up e a terra in un altro quello
della musica volando attraverso quello
dell'intrattenimento e la mia unicità
sta proprio in questo in questo mix
che calibro ormai da Ben 10 anni man
mano che cresco come persona come
professionista e man mano che Le
piattaforme si evolvono
quindi ha iniziato a truccarti nel 2013
no un po' prima
Tra l'altro in quel periodo ho scoperto
qualcosa di incredibile Sono nera
e non per vantarmi io ci ho messo quasi
subito a capirlo eh gli altri attorno a
me ci hanno messo un pochino di più per
esempio quando lavoravo in teatro in
camerino non trovo mai le nuance per me
e quindi dovevo portarmi i trucchi da
casa e quella situazione sembrava dirmi
Ma sì se vuoi l'attrice la puoi pure
fare però non puoi pensare di avere
tutto quello che hanno gli altri
oppure quando andavo in profumeria
c'erano queste signore che scoraggiavano
ogni mio tentativo di trovare prodotti
adatti al mio incarnato con frase tipo
Mato sei già sicura non hai bisogno del
fondotinta come se il fondotinta in
realtà non servisse a informare
l'incarnato
Poverine quelle signore non ce l'avevano
con me non volevano dirmi che trucchi
non erano a far mio non volevano farmi
sentire non all'altezza Eppure è
esattamente come io mi sentivo ogni
volta
ogni volta
perché il linguaggio
al potere di fare danni anche
involontariamente un po' come quando le
persone si complimentano con il mio
italiano la mia lingua madre
che mi fa questi complimenti veramente
convinto di essere gentile ma capite che
la frase ma come parli bene la nostra
lingua porta con sé un implicito per
essere come te
che finisce sempre Per colpirmi dritto
in faccia
una bambina che sente tutti quei
professionisti adulti che parlano in
quel modo inevitabile che a un certo
punto non si domandi se non sia lei
realmente a star sbagliando qualcosa
forse questo non è il posto per me
poi Parliamoci chiaro non è che io
avessi avuto tutti sti riferimenti in
televisione di donne sugli schermi ce ne
sono sempre state molto poche che mi
somigliassero ancora meno Sì c'è la
Beyoncé Naomi però loro erano delle
storie inarrivabili come degli alieni in
un'altra galassia e poi c'era upi e
Viola con la loro web comica io cosa
potevo fare le mie amiche non avevano le
mie stesse riflessioni Quindi io con
loro non ne potevo parlare però mi
dicevano che per qualunque situazione
intima o problematica che le affliggeva
avevano un asso nella manica capace di
dare tutte le risposte una sorta di
Passepartout miracolosa Insomma chiedere
a internet
anche io internet per me è stata una
folgorazione scoprire tutorial di
ragazze nere che insegnavano lingua
inglese come valorizzare il mio
incarnato c'era un problema però perché
non ho mai la gioia i prodotti che
usavano non erano disponibili in Italia
oppure erano difficilissimi da reperire
E quindi cosa facevo chiedevo a mia zia
in America di portare qualcosa oppure se
c'erano degli amici che andavano
all'estero gli chiedevo di comprarmi
qualche cosa sapete io conservo ancora
in un cassetto un fondotinta del 2014
per me era Preziosissimo lucentellinavo
la soluzione a questi problemi per me
sono diventate un'opportunità
e visto che non sono cresciuta con
riferimenti di persone nere che si
potevano raccontare nel 2013 ho aperto
su YouTube Grey's on your Dash facendo
tutorial su pelle scura in lingua
italiana per poter aiutare le persone
che come me in quel periodo cercavano
dei suggerimenti su come valorizzare
l'incarnato ma soprattutto lo scopo di
del canale era quello di creare uno
spazio di ascolto dove potersi esprimere
liberamente senza pregiudizi testando
insieme ai primi scritti un codice
linguistico che è educato la community
Affinché si comportasse in maniera
educata inclusiva soprattutto rispettosa
Ma su questa cosa ci torniamo dopo a
colpi di buchiris e tutorial leggeri
perché ho sempre pensato che se ti
diverti a simili di più abbiamo iniziato
a crescere e a creare massa critica e
quindi poi nel 2017 un Brand
importantissimo che fino al giorno prima
si nascondeva dietro noi fantomatiche
ricerca di di mercato secondo cui la
domanda di babbo
finalmente hanno deciso di estendere la
gamma di prodotti anche in Italia
fantastico
sembrava andare tutto bene fino a che la
community non è iniziato a chiedermi Ma
parlaci di te Ecco lì ho provato
veramente vergogna paura
Perché sì Io canto recito mi sono
eseguita davanti a gruppi golber Sono
qui davanti a voi oggi sono
emozionatissima però Ecco in quel
contesto specifico non avevo maschere da
indossare dovevo trovare la mia voce e
quindi piano piano abbiamo iniziato con
i q&a domande e risposte mentre facevo
questa cosa qui ho iniziato a rendermi
conto che in realtà il make up è un
pretesto per aprirsi con gli altri io
questo scambio che viene di momenti
intimi mi piace chiamarlo doppia
condivisione
e una volta che mi sono resa conto di
avere delle orecchie e se all'ascolto e
crescevano io avevo una voce in capitolo
ho deciso di dare voce anche ad altre
persone ed è così che è nato diversity
che sta per diversità italiana
e in questa rubrica c'erano delle
interviste ci sono delle interviste
makeup tutorial dove do voce a delle
persone che hanno una storia da
raccontare legata alla diversità perché
non c'è niente di più potente che
passare il microfono e dai versi ti
è diventato fondamentale anche tre anni
fa Ve lo ricordate quando eravamo chiusi
in casa
sempre davanti alle dirette a passare i
nostri giornata attraverso gli schermi
Ecco in quel periodo le persone hanno
iniziato a dire che chi faceva un lavoro
come il mio non avrebbe avuto tutti
questi problemi perché non avevamo un
negozio che doveva rimanere chiuso Sì
certo
però quando abbiamo iniziato a portare
le mascherine è obbligatoriamente per
due anni consecutive e le persone quasi
non si truccavano più Ecco perché a
farlo Parliamoci chiaro ti rimanevano
Mascherina e poi Ti toglievi la
mascherina eri un picasso Ecco in quel
periodo io ho assistito al cambio di
rotta di tantissimi canali o addirittura
la chiusura di tantissimi canali su
tutte le piattaforme
non perché sono più brava ma perché
ormai la community si era radicata
Avevamo condiviso emozioni e se non ci
si poteva truccare che problema c'era
Ormai il make up era solo uno dei filoni
del mio racconto sui social la
dimensione di intrattenimento da cui ero
partita prima di lavorare sul web aveva
dato una svolta a tutte le mie
piattaforme Adesso vi darò qualcosa di
incredibile la mia community non è fatta
solo di persone nere o persone
appassionate di Beauty o solo di donne
Ma come Sei nera ti trucchi chi ti
dovrebbe ascoltare
una volta una ragazzina mi ha scritto
non lo sai che io ti guardo sempre
insieme a mio papà perché sei divertente
papà Gli piace che non dici le parolacce
però le bippo e ancora una mamma ad un
evento mi ha detto che la mia risata le
calma l'ansia Ecco con questi feedback
Io ho capito che al di là del make up Al
di là del
dei consigli per gli acquisti Trend noi
possiamo essere utili alle persone in
tantissimi modi ultimamente si dibatte
sulla responsabilità
degli influencer rispetto alle loro
Community Io all'inizio ho detto di non
sentirmi un influencer ma responsabile
Sì per esempio di intervenire quando una
conversazione diventa troppo animata e
gli utenti iniziano ad utilizzare un
linguaggio inadeguato lì bisogna
intervenire Ovviamente io non posso
controllare tutto e tutti ma fare
educazione Sì Finché poi non è la
community stessa a regolarsi da sola che
poi le Community sono fatte di persone
Ricordiamocelo siamo persone al di qua e
al di là dello schermo
occupandoci di comunicazione ovvero di
relazione tra persone non si può
prescindere dalle parole
Perché queste danno vita a un pensiero e
al mondo intorno a noi così ciò che non
nominiamo non esiste invece quello che
nominiamo male rimane incastrato tra le
grate dei pregiudizio per questo che
dobbiamo sempre impegnarci ad usare un
linguaggio il più inclusivo possibile
all'inizio del mio discorso
parlavo del lessico violento utilizzato
dagli haters nei commenti
è un problema ma non solo questo è un
problema A volte anche le nostre parole
possono essere intrise di pregiudizio e
dello stesso disprezzo ad esempio come
quando una donna si sente dire ma non
vorrai mica andare in giro che si fa
così ecco quel non all'inizio e quel
così alla fine
racchiudono tutto il pregiudizio su come
la donna dovrebbe vestire
oppure come quando viene utilizzato un
linguaggio
non pensato che in realtà nasconde il
pregiudizio il privilegio e vecchie
regole sociali
che pretendono di stabilire cosa sia
normale Cosa no come ad esempio le calze
color carne noi sappiamo benissimo
perché questo termine nell'immaginario
collettivo rappresenta un colore che
oscilla tra il beige e il cipria Ma la
scelta di non pensare a un sinonimo
e ricorrere a quell'espressione lì è
nostra responsabilità poi ci sono altre
parole che
possono far male ossia quelle che
minimizzano non so se mi è capitato di
dire o di sentir dire Ah per me siamo
tutti uguali io non vedo colori e così
facendo minimizzate tutti i problemi
delle persone razzializzate che
affrontano ogni giorno
Ma chi me lo fa fare
chi me lo fa fare lo so a volte avere un
linguaggio inclusivo può essere una
faticaccia da gestire perché significa
in primis distruggere tutti quelli che
sono i nostri baeas inconsci che abbiamo
interiorizzato mentre stavamo crescendo
ne vale davvero la pena
[Musica]
io lascio rispondere a voi
tenendo conto che
il linguaggio che scegliamo
può restituire identità ed in Italia
persone
il linguaggio che scegliamo può far
sentire le persone accolte farle sentire
rispettate
un linguaggio inclusivo
tiene conto dei sentimenti le emozioni e
le scelte di chi parla con noi e questo
è un grande grandissimo esercizio di
empatia che ci rende persone
compassionevoli capace di essere in
grado di patire insieme agli altri ma
anche di
condividere le stesse passioni Quindi
secondo me
forse ne vale un po' la pena
Grazie
[Applauso]